[Musica]
parliamo di storia alzi la mano Chi di
voi odiava studiare la
storia non sono sola vi racconto un
piccolo segreto quando facevo
l'università all'esame di storia romana
sono stata bocciata Eh sì perché il
professore era molto legato alla storia
evenemenziale cioè alla rassegna
cronologica dei fatti più salienti ma a
me studiare la storia così non è mai
piaciuto ho anche provato a dirlo al
professore guardi Secondo me sarebbe
importante studiare i meccanismi della
storia capire il perché dei fatti
storici ma non c'è stato niente da fare
Mi ha
bocciato
non è neanche tutta colpa degli
insegnanti ci sono varie ragioni per cui
tante volte la storia viene studiata
così io non credo che sia utile
studiarla in questo modo però credo
nell'utilità della
storia però dobbiamo cercare di capire
che cosa sia una storia che può essere
utile anche che cosa sia la storia
perché tante volte vengono usate le
parole come se fossero sinonimi ad
esempio passato storia memoria e invece
sono tre concetti diversi quindi io
vorrei provare a definire la storia così
per
differenza Allora il passato È tutto ciò
che è accaduto in passato la serie degli
eventi che sono accaduti in passato
semplice la memoria invece è quello che
io ricordo del passato quello che io ho
una comunità al massimo ricordiamo del
passato Insomma è quello che mi
raccontava mio
nonno però affidarsi unicamente alla
memoria è come avere tra le mani una
Supercar rossa e non saperla guidare
bella e preziosa però ti porta fuori
strada per chiarire meglio questo
concetto Voglio condividere con voi un
ricordo
personale circa 25 anni fa esattamente
lo ricordo come fosse adesso era la
notte tra il 3 e il 4 luglio
1998 quella notte io proprio non
riuscivo a dormire per il caldo quel
giorno ero stata in piscina con le mie
amiche avevamo preso molto sole io forse
mi ero anche un po' scottata e quindi
c'è un fattore soggettivo se sentivo
molto caldo però mi sa che sentivano
molto caldo anche gli altri i miei
vicini Infatti tenevo la finestra della
camera aperta per poter far entrare un
po' di aria e anche i miei vicini
avevano le finestre aperte perché
sentivo la televisione le voci della
televisione arrivare dai loro
appartamenti in particolare ricordo che
nell'appartamento di fronte stavano
guardando un programma dove si
commentava la partita di calcio che la
nazionale italiana aveva giocato quel
pomeriggio contro la Francia e l'aveva
persa ai rigori una partita dei mondiali
di calcio forse la ricorderete anche voi
Il fatto è che noi tendiamo a ricordare
del passato soprattutto gli eventi più
brutti più traumatici che ci hanno
segnato in modo negativo ma se io di
quella singola notte faccio tutte le
notti del mio passato cioè se ricordo
solo quella singola notte generalizzo
quel ricordo a tutte le notti estive del
mio passato allora potrei pensare che in
passato abbia sempre fatto caldo come fa
caldo oggi e che in tutte le notti
estive non si riuscisse a dormire e
farei un
errore perché una rondine non fa
primavera e se invece vado a vedere le
serie storiche delle rilevazioni
scientifiche queste mi dicono che notti
come quella del 1998 erano rare
eccezionali e che poi poi nel tempo
progressivamente sono diventate sempre
più frequenti e che effettivamente oggi
noi stiamo assistendo a un progressivo
riscaldamento globale Ma questo la
memoria non me l'avrebbe potuto
dire e la memoria Poi ha tutti i difetti
che conoscete anche voi è l'abile
tendiamo a perderla nel tempo Voi vi
ricordate che cosa avete mangiato
mercoledì sera a cena Ecco io non mi
ricordo neanche che cosa ho mangiato
ieri sera
figuriamoci e arriviamo alla
storia la storia è il racconto di una
selezione di fatti che vengono
ricostruiti e interpretati cioè vengono
inseriti nel loro contesto e si cerca di
dare loro un senso vi stupirà Ma la
storia è una scienza pertanto utilizza
il metodo scientifico del confronto tra
le fonti non è perfetta Però si avvicina
alla realtà di quello che è stato in
passato molto più della memoria
Ma qual è la storia che può essere utile
a noi
oggi tante volte nei post che scrivo sui
social ci sono persone che commentano e
scrivono Ma cosa ce ne facciamo della
storia ma con tutti i problemi che
abbiamo nel presente non pensiamo sempre
al passato occupiamoci del
presente ma io penso proprio che la
storia possa aiutarci a capire meglio il
nostro presente e a capire come muoverci
nel futuro
soprattutto se noi non ci limitiamo alla
conoscenza storica ma capiamo i fatti
del passato e Quali fatti dovrebbero
interessarci di
più non penso sia tanto utile studiare
dei re degli Imperatori dei Condottieri
dei dittatori come tante volte si fa
Penso che possa essere più utile oggi
concentrare l'attenzione della storia
puntare i riflettori della storia sulle
persone comuni per andare a vedere
quand'è che le persone comuni si sono
fatte agenti di cambiamento quando hanno
determinato il loro
destino faccio un
esempio negli anni 60 Quindi negli anni
del boom economico e fino ai primi anni
70 qui su questo territorio che
all'epoca veniva chiamato comprensorio
ceramico abbiamo assistito a un
grandissimo sviluppo industriale ma
contemporaneamente sono saliti molto
anche i livelli di
inquinamento tanto che le persone
usavano dire che qui si mangiava pane e
polvere gli operai e le operaie si
ammalavano ma Si ammalavano anche le
loro famiglie e si ammalava l'ambiente
l'agricoltura come gli animali
d'allevamento
una situazione
insostenibile a un certo punto le
persone hanno deciso di fare qualcosa
Qualcosa è cambiato hanno cominciato a
farsi sentire a far sentire le loro voci
anche a mezzo stampa le persone comuni e
i medici e le loro proteste sono state
raccolte e rilanciate dai sindacati e
dagli enti pubblici e poi col tempo si è
arrivati a interessare gli imprenditori
ceramici e a trovare quelle soluzioni
che hanno permesso da un lato di non
chiudere le fabbriche e dall'altro di
ridurre notevolmente le emissioni e di
migliorare considerevolmente la
situazione allora noi oggi ci troviamo
di fronte ancora problemi legati
all'inquinamento magari più che altro
dovuto ad altri fattori ad esempio il
traffico veicolare
Ma io credo che oggi come Allora la
soluzione stia nelle nostre
mani perché come cantava De Gregori La
storia siamo noi attenzione nessuno si
sente
escluso faccio un altro esempio questa
volta voglio partire dal luogo dove ci
troviamo adesso se voi siete qui seduti
su quelle comode bellissime poltroncine
rosse ad ascoltare me che parlo
liberamente da questo palco è perché
questo luogo dove siamo l'Auditorium
Enzo Ferrari di Maranello nel tempo ha
subito delle
trasformazioni nasce nel
1927 come Casa del Fascio voluto dalla
dittatura fascista luogo di propaganda
del regime e poi durante la Seconda
Guerra Mondiale invece diventa luogo di
rifugio di sosta per tutti quei profughi
italiani in fuga dalla guerra se noi con
la macchina del tempo potessimo tornare
indietro Qui invece delle poltroncine
vedremo tanti giacigli di paglia e
persone in particolare donne bambini
anziani sdraiati per terra a
riposare e poi nell'immediato secondo
dopo guerra questo stesso luogo diventa
un presidio
Democratico perché qui hanno la loro
sede associazioni di donne e uomini che
provano a costruire a sognare poi a
costruire concretamente un mondo nuovo
all'insegna della Libertà all'insegna
della Giustizia Ecco la storia non torna
mai uguale e le sfide che oggi ci
aspettano sono sicuramente diverse però
determinati meccanismi si
ripetono meccanismi che hanno
determinato ad esempio prima l' ignorare
un problema per Ragioni varie per
convenienza economica per interessi
personali per abitudini consolidate e
poi il decidere di affrontare di
riconoscere quel problema e provare a
risolverlo sono i meccanismi della
storia che dovremmo
provare a
capire oggi noi parliamo di
evoluzione quindi di cambiamento a volte
qualcuno vorrebbe fermare il tempo ma
questo non è veramente possibile altri
vorrebbero tornare indietro nel tempo e
neanche questo è
possibile ci sono state teorie che hanno
detto che il passare del tempo avrebbe
provocato inevitabilmente un progresso e
altre teorie che invece hanno detto il
contrario che col passare del tempo
inevitabilmente saremmo andati verso
un'involuzione
Beh io credo che non ci sia nulla di già
scritto nulla di
predeterminato e che le cose stiano
nelle nostre mani che noi possiamo farci
agenti di cambiamento come altri hanno
fatto prima di noi perché le cause degli
eventi storici sono complesse Ma in
questa complessità credo che ci sia
spazio anche per le responsabilità
individuali e Allora potremmo
interrogare il
passato per avere risposte Forza
coraggio per vivere un'evoluzione
sostenibile per scrivere la storia che
[Applauso]
[Musica]
vivremo
a